[Music]
this week on cue a Wall Street Journal
staff reporter and columnist Alexandra
wolf she discusses her book valley of
the gods a Silicon Valley story
[Music]
Alexandra wolf what is the valley of the
gods the valley of the gods is this book
about these three and focuses on three
fellows who who won this Peter Peter
teals
teal fellowship and so they it it looks
through the eyes of these three kids and
it shows sort of the cultural
anthropology of Silicon Valley right now
and hopefully a few other alternatives
to going to college so what did why did
you do this well why did I do it to
begin with I mean I just I guess I I've
always grown up in New York I've always
lived in New York and I went out to
Silicon Valley for the first time a
couple years ago and I was so amazed by
what I saw there I was so refreshed by
the optimism and I mean every time
reading the paper there changing every
single industry and being there I just
found way more than than I ever thought
I would I would see on the East Coast it
was so different you lead off with the
author's note first thing you say is I
first met Peter Thiel the co-founder of
PayPal Managing Partner of fondest fund
and first investor in facebook in New
York at a salon at his house in 2006
yeah go back to the salon and who was
Peter teal and why were you there so I
met him through some friends my parents
and he at that point in New York nobody
really knew who he was and he was really
famous on the west coast for founding
PayPal and he'd become he'd been the
first investor in facebook but then
Facebook was not the Mahima that it is
today it was big but it wasn't the site
billions that you know at the size of it
is now and and so I go to the salon and
and these friends at OU you you might
find him interesting he could be an
interesting subject and I got there and
he had these people presenting at his
house
and they all were saying things that
were completely counterintuitive so and
if they said it out loud at their job
they would have gotten fired so it was
all these sort of politically incorrect
things or contrarian ideas and they
would get up and present and it was
really the only forum where they could
do it and I thought this was so
fascinating that this guy knew all of
these people who were saying things with
which at the time sounded crazy but some
of them turned out to be right he was
talking about he predicted the the
real-estate bubble so back in 2006 he's
saying oh this is gonna crash and
everybody's saying well my apartment
just you know appreciated by millions of
dollars so what are you talking about
but then some of those predictions came
true so it was really interesting
New York is where you grew up where'd
you go to college Duke University why
did you pick that spot my father's
family was from down there and so I was
comfortable with it but also so it was
it was totally different than this sort
of the New England Ivy League schools
and I applied there early and I just
thought it was so I just thought it was
fun to get a different part of the
country if you look closely our audience
can pick out a face that looks familiar
when you talk about your father who is
your father
only wears a different color than I do
his name's Tom Wolfe and he wears white
suit and he he wrote bonfire of the
vanities and the Wrights death and what
else did he write a couple other books
Electric kool-aid acid test yes and he's
speaking the like electric cool acid
test I want to show you some video of
Ken Kesey okay because I get a sense he
you mentioned him in his book yeah in
your book and I get a sense of what you
found in Silicon Valley has some
connection to this it really let's watch
a little bit of this okay
[Music]
[Music]
go ahead would you repeat that again
we weren't old enough to be beatnik so
we were a little too old to be hippies
everybody I knew had read on the road it
stirred us up so we decided to go travel
across the country since it turned out
that there were so many of us because we
decide we buy a bus it was like a troupe
of minstrels there's this guy with no
shirt up talkin Melamed Cassidy was
gonna drive the bus it looked like a
traveling pleasure palace it was big
roomy and spacious until we got all the
people in it we take turns riding
shotgun with him it was almost
impossible for him to ever shut off all
you can do is experience this thing can
really believe that things could be
changed he saw himself as a kind of
liberator people didn't think we were
hippies or that we were drug freaks
because it wasn't in the news yet the
public always Fred when they saw that
bus
[Music]
once Pandora's box is open you can't
regulate who gets to use the stuff that
slides out of it
I thought this was as American as you
can get because we were exploring a new
territory that was from a documentary a
lot of things I want to ask you about
first when did you read your father's
book electric kool-aid acid test
probably a couple of years ago and it
was strangely relevant to this book
because this book originally it was
supposed to be a bus trip that was a
reverse of the electric kool-aid acid
test
so they Peter teal and the foundation
that he that works for him they were
gonna rent out the opposite of Ken
Kesey's Mary pray 1939 Harvester school
of us that we just saw and outfit it to
be this high tech dorm and they went to
Tennessee and they found Justin Bieber's
old tour bus and they're gonna have it
all decorated in in in and sort of
computers and electronics and those than
that and they ended up canceling the bus
trip two weeks before but but it was
completely based on that whole were you
gonna go on that bus yeah I was gonna go
I was gonna be a month we were gonna
stop at colleges a long way and I was
gonna go from New York to Palo Alto
instead of Palo Alto to the East Coast
and it was supposed to be a rejection of
all of the things that institutions on
the East Coast had done that were
Timothy Leary from the electrical from
the from the Ken Kesey's circle and
became a professor and then this new
version of the bus is gonna take all
these kids away from the professor's
that were you know said things that that
that that they disagreed with what would
in your opinion be the difference in the
politics of the Ken Kesey crowd versus
the crowd that you got to know out there
well in a weird way it they wouldn't be
even that different because I mean if
you if you were to say Ken Kesey I mean
now a lot of the people I met out there
were libertarian so it actually you know
in a strange way wasn't all that
different their behavior it was
definitely different it was a completely
different kind of drug the drug was in a
massive internet success versus acid but
but a lot of the similarity I mean I I
remember I asked my father I told him
that I was writing this book and he
oh yeah you know I I wrote about that in
1983 it was the story about Robert Noyce
and it was called the tinkering zuv
Robert Noyce one of the Intel founders
and and a lot of things were were so
similar just the way everybody dressed
and these Co living communes and I
thought you know dad you scooped me but
all he did in a lot of ways but but the
but for that story particularly he he he
sort of wrote about that first that that
people didn't wear a necktie out there
that everything was really casual well
when you were out there hanging around
them and you wear a hoodie hey I have a
lot more hoodies now than I did in 2011
what's the effect what what is the the
hoodie business oh I think it's I think
it's an imitation of Mark Zuckerberg I
kind of think a lot of people a lot of
entrepreneurs that go out there and they
want to be a founder of a company they
they think that that venture capitalists
will fund them if they look like
successful entrepreneurs and so I kind
of feel like weirdly Mark Zuckerberg
started this whole fashion craze no one
would ever accuse him of being
particularly fashionable but now
everybody has a hoodie and actually my
father was telling me this funny story
that he went out to to interview someone
about about hedge funds and and and
digital technology and and he said that
that one of these companies was saying
that it was so weird when a Wall Street
banker came out there to try to I think
they're gonna try to undo the IPO and of
one of the big tech companies and and he
came in where he was 75 years old and
came and wearing a hoodie and sneakers
and everyone just laughed
cuz you see if they'd seen him in a suit
all the time and he's an investment
banker but it really seems to a spread I
mean if I went into a company out there
looking like this they think that I was
going to the prom so you know I mean
nobody whereas a dress or a skirt it's
or anything like that
speaking of dress here is your father
when he was here and this is one of the
most memorable moments he won't like
this well maybe you will let's do this
what articles would say what an
interesting man
he wears white suits so it was it took
the play
of a personality for many years how many
of them do you have I used to have a lot
of them but I've got about 22 now I can
get by with my how long can you wear
them without having to have them clean
that's six hours when you honor to go on
a trip and make people think you have
one you have to have three and I have
three suits I brought along to come here
all made of the same material you can't
really tell the difference but you know
it really it simply has not hurt to have
a trademark what have you learned from
your father about writing food asked him
because I'm a reporter I'm so used to
asking questions that I'm not really you
know I'm so not used to answering them
so I asked my dad at the beginning of
when I when this book came out I said
how do you answer questions and he said
well I just want like soot then I didn't
have to and you know no matter what I
said I was interesting as I had the
white Sunna and I said well I can't
really wear a white suit I guess you'll
be fine would you know everybody knows
about the white suits the the fact that
was interesting was the 22 of them does
he wear them around the house in New
York when he's there I'm sure yeah I
mean he has some variations he has them
is this really nice smoking jacket that
sometimes he'll put over the white suit
if he goes to the doctor if he goes to
shopping definitely a white suit he goes
to the gym every day though and he
doesn't wear white to the gym he has he
wears a navy to the gym he has a white
guy of era I mean he's pretty inventive
so go back to the west coast and one of
the things I picked up in your book is
there is a huge difference between the
East Coast and the west coast I did
happen to think because I'm from the
Midwest you left out the rest of the
country but what is this difference what
is this difference between east and west
well I feel like the biggest difference
is actually in the status systems in the
eat on the East Coast you have it's it's
vertical it's a hierarchy and you pay
your dues and then you get to the next
level traditionally speaking and then on
the west coast it's so much more
horizontal so to get in with a group are
these networks and so you sort of
laterally move into a certain network
and it doesn't really matter how old you
are or I mean as long as we reckon he
but you could be old or young or
anything or or you just have to be sort
of connected and have and have the same
status values in a way for example in
the book a lot of these kids who went
out there to try to be the gods of
Silicon Valley like Elon Musk or Peter
Thiel would copy their idiosyncrasies
instead of copying their brilliance
because that was much harder and so they
would take on these interests in living
forever or you know becoming paleo or or
the seasteading the Institute which is
these libertarian colonies in the ocean
that Patrick Friedman came up with he
was the son of or the grandson of Milton
Friedman and and so it was it was sort
of by interest that people grouped
together whereas in New York where I
grew up it felt like it was you go to
this kind of college you get this kind
of job you climb the ladder so that was
a really big distinction that I that I
thought that what does it mean going
paleo oh you can't have any carbs or you
can't have any refined carbs no sugar
everything has to be natural things that
have that have had a Paleolithic caveman
would have eaten all right you talked
about Milton Friedman we've got some
video when I show the first thing most
you're gonna see is the grandfather his
son and his son who you write about
let's watch that whatever you have had
an improvement in the conditions of the
ordinary people over any lengthy time
it's been an account of society and yet
everybody is extending socialism I think
one should have a society without
government that I think in the short run
there are some things government does
that you should stop doing tomorrow and
some that we will take some years to
replace we've talked about the nature of
the ocean today it's it's a unique place
it's a dynamic medium that mixes things
that allows movement and that makes it
perfect for societal evolution
why is patrie the grandson of Milton
Friedman and the son of David Friedman
in your book well because he Peter Thiel
funded these islands that he wanted to
build out in the ocean and it's called
the seasteading Institute and
seasteading yes and so after I think
it's outside of 12 miles away from shore
then you're under you're outside of US
jurisdiction and so the idea was to have
these floating islands where you could
create your own government there and so
they had all these models for it and
each one cost $500,000 and Peter Thiel
gave him $500,000 and I don't know if it
would be an investment technically but
gave him five thousand five hundred
thousand dollars I think as he thought
it was such a unique idea and so that's
how patrie Friedman met Peter teal and
then he helped out with the fellowship
this 20 under 20 program that that the
main characters in the book were part of
and he helped look at the applications
and he he was there at the beginning
mentoring some of them well what would
be the difference between Petri Friedman
and say his grandfather in lifestyle oh
well
Patri Friedman used to be used to have
this polyamorous lifestyle he lived in
this commune in Mountain View called
Tortuga and now he's actually monogamous
and engaged to a nice woman and they
have the same they have one relationship
but before he had a co-parent and the
and then they had roommates and they all
sort of lived as one big happy family
and he's also you patrie also with is
much less establishment clearly than
than his grandfather I mean his his
ideas were really out of the box I mean
they were less just pure
economics and and more just completely
to me that I'd never heard anything like
it before I just thought I just thought
his point of view was really really
refreshing and new and he's and he's
he's such an odd character I mean I
remember I first I think one of the
first times I met him was on this cruise
ship with all these tech entrepreneurs
and he's wearing a Burger King crown and
this purple cape and he's running on
with those fives sneakers that he just
looked like somebody from a different
planet so he made for a good book
character what would his politics be and
how much would he agree or disagree with
his grandfather oh I mean I think in a
way there's a thread that unites them I
mean he's he's he's extremely
libertarian I mean I think he actually
has deals to work with countries to
actually start entirely new governments
and he had a he and his friend James
Hogan they worked on this and it was
this experimental pre version of
seasteading called a femoral and you'd
go up and you there's this lake and
everybody would bring these rafts and
they'd experiment in all sorts of
government's styles and I can't imagine
that Milton Friedman actually did that
so so he's into he seemed like he
actually tried these things and lives
this way which was interesting to write
about no you work at The Wall Street
Journal how often do you write where can
people see what you do Oh twice a week
so so I have one column about art and
then I have another column which is a
profile of a different person every
every week already getting confidential
you and that's in that's the art section
yeah the review weekend sections that
exactly you did a profile recently on
your father yes what was that like oh it
was so intimidating because it was sort
of I mean I I did I I wanted to try to
do it justice and try to do it in his
own style which was even harder so I had
all these you know I had at all these I
put all these expectations on myself but
my father was so agreeable so he made it
a lot better but I think I started it
out the early an early draft was going
dad because he starts out so many of his
articles with so many exclamation points
and and and
I also he'd just written a book that
that uh I think was was pretty
controversial um but it would get it was
weird I mean he wasn't he was very
accessible so that was helpful I'm
getting the interview what was he
impacted both your father and your
mother had on you and you have a brother
Tommy yeah what's he like and what's he
do
oh he's this great artist he's AM he
makes furniture and he built sculptures
and he's um and he makes jewelry and
things like that and he lives in
Brooklyn with his wife and well he and
my father are probably the most moral P
and my mother I shouldn't say that mom
if you're watching no but they're the
most moral people he's one of those
people who they're they're very
principled there's no gray area there's
right and there's wrong and I always
respected that about him but he still
he's gone over the years into some
strange environment yeah as have you
right yes I mean that I think the other
thing about that is that when he goes
into these strange environments he looks
even stranger because he doesn't try to
adapt to them so I always thought that
was so interesting because you know I
asked him when he was reporting the book
for the electric kool-aid acid test if
he ever what he wore and he's over a
suit and a tie and you know I carried a
notebook and I think that's what he's
done for every single book I mean he's
never he's just in life he's never tried
to fit in and when you're when I'm I
like going into situations that are
uncomfortable reporting but um but I
always think about him because I had
that human reaction of thinking oh how
do I fit in what are they gonna think
but then he always reminds me you don't
have to fit in you're just a fly on the
wall you're just reporting the scene
like who cares what they think
and so there have been so many reporting
trips where I've gone on right where I
don't feel like I fit in and when I
remember I went to I went to Malawi with
boots Gucci Fashion Group and I felt so
out of place and I just remember my
father's I see you don't have to dress
like you're you know in the Gucci PR
department you're writing about them so
so that's really been helpful and then I
mean even about Silicon Valley my father
was out there I think reporting I am
Charlotte Simmons but he was staying at
a hotel near Stanford
he doesn't try to look like a professor
even so he's wearing this really nice
suit and he has a tie on and he said he
was leaving his hotel restaurant and
somebody stopped him on the way out and
tried to give him a tip because I
thought he was a waiter and so it's sort
of these things that happen and he just
gets a kick out of it so it's sort of
it's it's um I definitely try to think
about that if I'm if I'm reporting on
somewhere did you read I'm Charlotte
salmon I did yes and I have a t-shirt
that says I am NOT Charlotte Simmons
because everybody said oh it's it's so
much like Duke oh it's so much like
you're like your life and the plot thank
goodness was not my life but a lot of
them for characteristics I could
understand and so so yes I have I have
my t-shirt that I when he does something
like that has he talked to you about
that book before it comes out yeah I
mean he did we did talk about cuz I was
in college when he was writing he talked
to my brother and I we both he and he
came to he came to Chapel Hill to do
some of the reporting cuz I refused to
let him come to Duke and I remember
calling him one morning for breakfast as
a dad it's 10:00 you ready for breakfast
and he's like I'm so tired of it a frat
party till 3:00 a.m. last night can we
just do it a little later and I did hear
a lot about it but but ya know I had the
same boyfriend all through college and
in this book this woman dates about you
know 20 people or something so so I feel
like I always have to have this
disclaimer I'm not relative it's better
but it was really fun hearing my
father's take on all of these all of
these people and he gave sorry I'm going
on too long but he gave this he gave our
graduation talk and it was part of it
became part of this essay he wrote
hooking up and it was so embarrassing
because it's in front of my entire
college class and I just wanted to put a
bag over my head because he said you
know the whole courtship rituals have
changed completely you know you meet
somebody and then you you know eyes lock
lips lock hips lock and then the next
morning you say what's your name
and everybody in the whole student body
looks at me like what did what did you
tell him yeah so back to this book
there was a quote that I wanted to read
back to you from a man named John
Burnham oh yeah it's relevant to what we
do in this town he says take two my John
and I'll show you a clip in a minute
take democracy for one why he wondered
did everyone believe in it so blindly
instead John thought democracy was
really oligarchy government by a select
few he borrowed this idea from mold
Berg's blog then look for the same
concept in Plato Plato his magnificent
he said matter-of-factly do they really
believe that democracy is a bad idea I
think some of them do John Vernon was
the most precocious boy I'd ever met I
mean he had read everything he was so he
wasn't necessarily a bad student but he
was so badly behaved because he was so
ahead of the game I mean he would he'd
read the the school reading and eleventh
and twelfth grade was so boring to him
that he just read these blogs and he
read philosophy all day but I think
actually he I mean he's he's he didn't
get involved in politics but he was so
interested in those ideas and he applied
to the fellowship with that with that
idea we got we have to stop and talk
about Peter teal for a moment and the
fellowship before I show you john byrne
what what who is Peter teal today and
how does he factor in this you see it
met him ten years ago in the salon so
today now he so the lens that I really
view him through in this book is through
the through this fellowship to convince
these students to drop out of college
but today he's gotten a lot of attention
lately obviously for supporting Trump's
presidency but but he's an investor and
he's he still makes a lot of angel he
works for a founder he was a partner at
founders fund a venture capital firm in
San Francisco and he's sort of known as
this Godfather of the PayPal mafia and
these people who he worked at PayPal
with and have gone on to create huge
companies such as Jeremy Stoppelman of
Yelp and then elizy oh he's in his late
forties and how much is he worth Oh
probably about two billion let's watch a
little bit of Peter Thiel so we can see
what he looks like exactly I've been a
big critic of the u.s. education system
focus a lot on higher education where
you have this a runaway student debt we
now have over a trillion dollars of
student debt I think we have a bubble in
higher education and I think that it is
I do not think that it is actually
helping people do more entrepreneurial
or more risk-taking things when you
graduate from college with a hundred
thousand dollars of debt you will take a
safe reasonably well-paying job to pay
off your debt and you will be much less
likely to do something entrepreneurial
or creative or artistic which may pay
less but ultimately create more value
when did he create this fellowship how
many are involved in it how old are they
the story behind the teal fellows so he
started in 2010 and then he announced it
at TechCrunch and at first he thought it
was going to be another one of these
contrarian ideas that everybody says oh
you're crazy but it weirdly caught on I
mean so many people seem to agree with
him because of what he mentioned with
the over trillion dollars of student
debt and he thought of college is sort
of a four-year vacation where you don't
really learn that much if you're not
motivated to do so and so he the first
year he had he made this announcement
that he was looking for 20 kids under
age 20 to start new different companies
out west and drop out and 400 people
applied and it's still going on and now
5,000 people apply every year what do
they get and they get $100,000 and then
they get they I guess think now they got
a lot more mentorship and they have
meetings every week or so with the
leadership of the program where can they
live so they don't provide housing so
it's so actually it's really hard they
have to they have to find housing
themselves and they have to come up with
an idea themselves and they have to get
to get it funded themselves so the the
teal foundation doesn't give them any
money other than the hundred thousand
dollars and I think it's it stretches
over two years so it's actually not that
easy to do do they have to live in
Silicon Valley that's the preference
some of them don't but they don't have
to but they they encourage them to live
and where is Silicon Valley oh where is
it it's south of San Francisco so it
sort of
it would be it encompasses a pretty big
area but no it's right they most of the
fellows lived in Palo Alto and around
Stanford its San Jose out there those
places but what what's located in there
how many of those companies did you come
in contact with you mean of the fellows
no just didn't you know as you went
around and them you know what's all
there oh so um some of the biggest tech
companies I I saw that Facebook is there
Google is in coop ISM Google's there
Apple's there is paid router people I
think it is there I should double-check
that but um back because it's so funny I
didn't I barely even put PayPal in the
book because Peter Thiel founded it so
long ago and then they sold it to eBay
but um but I mean that's one of the
things that seemed like such a simple
idea that took that was so hard and I
think a lot of these kids look at these
huge ideas you take Twitter you take
uber Airbnb and they seem like
conversationally almost like a Seinfeld
episode oh if only we had this then this
could happen
and they felt like oh I could just do
this like this and it was so much harder
I mean the work required was just was so
surprising to me because a lot of them
felt like they were these hot it was it
felt like the rush of Hollywood
actresses to LA and they end up being a
waitress and they wait for their big day
but I feel like it's harder to be Elon
Musk than Tom Cruise I mean you have to
be so many of these companies Instagram
uber the people running them you know
didn't just have a lucky break the
stories were just years and years and
years of coding and engineering and I
mean they have qualifications that I
can't even imagine it just in the when
they're covered in the press they've
exploded so I think it caused a lot of
people to come out there just assuming
that this would happen and then they
were disappointed here is a group of the
first fellows which was in 2011 this was
December and it was just it's only 45 my
proposal is to cure aging I'm interested
in keeping information accessible and
and free for people my current project
is to build an open-source larger spray
message
to make learning games for young
children between the ages of 7 and 13
rotating a solar panel so that it can
optimize the amount of electricity
advanced mobility aid that will allow
disabled users to go essentially
anywhere that an able-bodied human can
make it easier for everyday people who
like music to go to more live events
bioethanol is the energy of the future
for under 25 cents a gallon from waste
products of cellulose our goal is to
make solar energy cheaper than coal
without government subsidies my project
is on an electric motor for electric
vehicles I'm applying to pursue asteroid
mining
John Burnham their last asteroid mining
yes how old was he when he started in
all of us oh he was really he was 20 so
he was pretty they have to be under 20
yeah injury under 20 so when he applied
he was what are the rules about college
oh the you can't you wait you have to
even further the fellowship yeah so you
had to you could stop out you could go
back after two years but you had to drop
out for those two years one in them and
Skyy John Marv buck started Wake Forest
for a year and then I'm sorry for a
semester and then dropped out but it
cost him his his teammates the his other
team started without him and he had he
was left starting his own company so
ideally they had to just completely drop
out and then ten percent went back to
college so of each some don't yeah a lot
of them don't actually so do they start
companies yeah they all started
companies or some of them worked for
existing companies but they all came up
with an idea and tried to make it work I
mean John Burnham the company that he
started he actually didn't end up
starting an asteroid mining company but
he started a company that would try to
make online payments and gold and you
could do it on your mobile phone and
that didn't work out so he ended up
going back to Dartmouth and he's still
at Dartmouth but a lot of them stayed
out there but you say in your book that
he went from asteroid mining to the
religion yes oh so he went so he that is
he went he had so many back and forth
that his story was so interesting to me
because the ups and downs were colossal
but he so after that didn't work out he
went to Dartmouth and then he came up
with a new idea
and then he posted it on a blog it was
picked up and it became so promising
that he moved back to California then he
became disenchanted with the life out
there so then he went to Thomas More
which is this really tiny religious
school in New England and any study
religion and he became really into
religion and then now he's dropped out
of that school and he's he's already
transferred to a Dartmouth back to
Dartmouth so when did you start on this
project and this is your first book
first book yeah I started I guess I
started the reporting in 2010 and then
over the next two three years it was out
there pretty much half the time so how
did you do it I mean what how did you
become a part of their lives well I
guess I'm gonna interviewed probably
more than a hundred people and I and I
knew since I had known Peter Thiel and
met some people who he worked with at
the fellow at the foundation who ran the
fellowship I just went to those final
rounds and I started meeting the fellows
and and it was so interested in right in
the idea of just education and what
needs to be done about higher education
and that was such an interesting window
because even just the parents reactions
were so interesting because when I was
growing up I'm 36 when I was growing up
if you didn't go to college there was
something wrong with you or you were
having problems whereas now the parents
at least of these kids were it was the
first time I'd heard them be proud of
their kids and I going to college and it
was this other alternative to actually
having to take this track and I liked
the idea of not having to go down that
road and you know if I had if I had if I
were applying now to school to college
maybe I would try to think of something
different I don't know if I would start
a company in Palo Alto of it but I feel
like it did make me question other ideas
instead of just having to do these four
years of higher education so what was it
like growing up in the Tom Wolfe and
what was your mom like Erin she's still
here but what was she what was her
interests
oh she's I mean my she's really she's a
she used to be a graphic designer
I guess she still is but she worked at
Harper's Magazine for a long time
and my father I only remember of him I
mean I remember many things about him
but in terms of his work growing up
there was just at the door he had a
tight use on his typewriter all the time
so I heard the sound of the typewriter
the entire time growing up he still use
a typewriter and so my mother I guess
she she helps my she's helped my father
a lot with his books and and she she she
reads all of his drafts and she's read
all of mine so it's like would you have
been would you have been a writer if it
hadn't have been for the family you grew
up and how big an impact did that have
on you oh I think I actually I don't
think I would have been I mean I think I
always liked your English I always liked
writing but but I I used to I watched
what it was so fascinating to me I
remember when I my father's personality
and then I read he's so polite you know
I've never heard him curse out loud and
then I read bonfire the vanities and I
was like daddy used the f-word and I
couldn't believe that somebody of his
comportment would write about could get
in the minds of all these other
characters who had who were so different
than him and I thought that was so
interesting that you could be so
different on the page and then you are
in person in Charlotte Simmons oh yeah
full of oh my gosh yeah I mean language
it really was how do you know about
those things dad but but yeah so that
was funny and then I guess I interned at
this this freebie magazine out in Long
Island and I think cuz they were
short-staffed I wrote this restaurant
review and they just printed it as is
and I think I was reading the agony and
the ecstasy about Michelangelo that
summer for summer reading so I wrote I
started it saying as in the agony and
the ecstasy chef Michael Smith puts his
pepperoni on his pizza and I thought I
was so amazing and they published it as
it was so I had a falsely inflated view
of my own writing expertise and then
they subsequently ran an actual review
of the restaurant but but it helped
working for these places that were
understaffed and didn't edit you but
that was the first writing job at
fifteen where else have you worked
before you got to the Wall Street
Journal and how long
you been there oh I worked at UM I
worked at the New York Observer right
out of college which was so much fun
because um
you could I mean I think if you had a
good idea they would hire a bum off the
street if they had a good up there was
no bureaucracy and you felt like you're
at the zeitgeist of New York it's just
it was so fun and it done it was an ER I
was there well before him but um but
then after we oh then I went to the Wall
Street Journal and then I went to Conde
Nast portfolio wrote for Vanity Fair a
little bit and then on contract not um
not on staff and then joined the Wall
Street Journal three or four years ago
four years ago but years ago you wrote
about James Comey I did yes they did
that's so true what were those
circumstances oh that's so funny so I so
that was around the time when um when
Martha Stewart was was was being
prosecuted and and I was all it was that
spate of white-collar criminals and and
he was his office was he was a he was a
it was he was in New York the u.s. he
was at the Southern District of New York
and he so I did this profile of him and
then we didn't run it for a little while
later and so it was it was actually so
it ended up being weirdly timely I'd
love to profile him again but I don't
know if he'd be as available Betty are
you surprised about what happened to him
based on what he said in your interview
he was pretty careful in my interview I
mean he didn't really say anything he
didn't really give any knew he didn't I
he was pretty crowded here and I was
gonna read back a quote yeah that I
thought it might be interesting yeah
that's it I regret that you found this
article yeah where is it quote this
criminal case this is Martha Stewart is
about lying lying to the FBI lying to
the SEC and lying to investors he said
at the June 4th press conference this is
back in 2003 yeah that is conduct that
will not be tolerated huh well that's
it's interesting and thinking about that
now with the election but was he open to
talking to you background with it you
mean it last laughing when you
interviewed no no when when was he could
you interview him or yeah actually I
mean I remember
I am I met with his his uh he had a
press officer that I would I met with
four hours before I met with him because
at the time I was 23 I think and I
really didn't know very much about law I
mean I needed an education before I met
with him so I met with all these lawyers
and I talked to you know I interviewed
tons of people I think it took three
weeks to prepare for this because just
because I was so new to it and and he
was so friendly he was everybody I
interviewed about him was them was a was
so positive about him and I I guess I'd
never have expected the FBI but back
then it was the different it was a
different time but he was certainly
getting a lot of attention for those
white-collar criminals one of the women
that is prominent in your book a couple
chapters on Laura Deming yeah here here
she is
sometimes I've talked to people they say
well you know if I lived to be a hundred
or two hundred I'd get bored pretty
quickly I can't understand that all my
morning walks over to MIT I love looking
at things and just thinking about all
those physics that goes into things like
waves or things like trees were either
cellulose on the outside of the cell
life is mind-blowingly exciting
sometimes we lose track of that there's
no better way to remember that than to
think about what it would be like to die
and and not experience that I want to
cure aging I want to make us all live
forever
how old is Lord Deming now 22 and she go
to MIT after she became a fellow no she
went for it to age 14 so yes she became
a she she joined the UC Berkeley a lab
at UC Berkeley and at 12 and then and
then went to 42 MIT at 14 and she's so
fascinated to talk to you because she
finds biology and science so interesting
and she gets so excited about it and I I
was so impressed by her I have to say
she was so different than why did she do
the fellowship well I think she already
had been to college and and here was
this network of people including this
guy named dr. Aubrey de Grey who has
this his whole research is based around
ending the disease aging so Peter Thiel
had given him three million dollars to
look into anti-aging or curing the aging
disease and and so he was one of her
mentors and there were a lot of people
in that in the foundation and involved
with the fellowship who were were really
interested in helping people live
forever
and so she done she's really
knowledgeable she's been working with
worms trying to help them live forever
since she was 12 so it was a good it was
a good fit there's another person in
your book Paul goo oh yeah yeah what
there's this strange fascination I think
especially in Silicon Valley with people
who have dropped out and I think it's
because of a logical fallacy that goes
something like this I had heard of a
person called
star for birdie I know he dropped out of
college I know he made a lot of money
I hear you dropped out of college that
must mean you're gonna make a lot of
money like marks are
and and so you know surprisingly I've
actually found that I think people tend
to be more positively inclined towards
listening to what I'm saying when I tell
them that I've dropped out which which
is kind of weird if that's not a reason
to listen more to me hmm what about Paul
goo well he was so interesting because
he started this company called upstart
and it gave it gave people who didn't
necessarily it was it was a
person-to-person lending company so it
was it did this similar thing as the
fellowship in that if you didn't feel
like you wanted to try to get a high
paying job at a bank or a consulting
company and you wanted to be an artist
you could ask you would get a loan from
another person and there would be people
who would fund you through this through
this company and but they were he had
this algorithm to figure out the risk of
funding a particular person and it was
so interesting because a lot of it was
trying to I mentioned the book but to
quantify character and so they had all
these ways of deciding what somebody's
character was and they were all data
points and I thought it was such a weird
thing that you could hack character and
I guess it was one of those examples out
there of people trying to hack
everything morality character right and
wrong and and he's a really disciplined
guy I think it was just he just found it
to be an interesting practice can you
describe the difference maybe this isn't
fair but you talk about your dad being
so moral yeah your parents can you
describe the morality of your father
versus the morality of these young kids
that you write about huh oh that's
that's a really interesting question and
more holiday my father versus these KITT
well in a way I kind of feel like there
I kind of feel like they're similar in
that my father I wrote this story in
high school called and it was you have
to pick somebody who swims against the
tide and so my father I wrote how he
literally did he always worked you know
he wore a two-piece bathing suit to the
beach and I'd be like hello mr. wolf you
know in for a suit everywhere and and
the ideas that Hill the
none of the things he'll say he just is
so tickled by the fact that other people
will find it crazy that he's saying this
and so because and I just think that's
so brave
and so I think that you like that at all
I would like to be I'm probably less
like that than my father but um it helps
when you have more legs to stand on I
think after you've written a couple of
best-selling books and then people take
you more seriously if you say crazy
things if you haven't then they just
look at you like you're crazy probably
maybe that's not across the board but
but I guess a lot of the people in in
Silicon Valley were okay saying things
that that others might find immoral or
not or not I mean my father definitely
has a more traditional marriage than a
lot of people out there and I do they
marry it all I mean you talk about
polyamory yeah it's definitely not
across the board but I met people there
who who and not and I I wouldn't say
that polyamory is immoral it's
transparent at least but but just his
ways of behaving are definitely
different than different than theirs and
I guess what else would be different the
other thing is is that while these
people out in Silicon Valley are so
different from each other so different
from from the East Coast sometimes it
feels like a uniform out there too and I
think my father is um I mean almost
morally opposed to any kind of uniform
that he does not want to have to fit
into anything and I think a lot of the
behavior out there is everything the
hoodie for example is to fit in by the
way did you read by bonfire of the
vanities yes how much of that came true
oh very true and and let's go to another
one of your people that you write about
James proud oh yeah here's 45 seconds of
James Brown oh great the inspiration
basically came from a friend trying to
find tears to a concert and it was
pretty difficult and there must be an
easier way to do that so I went away and
thought about this for a week or so or
actually there's actually something that
could be built here so I just built as a
side project and then released it one
summer and
it got traction okay I've been doing
this for fun I could take all this
different data for like music stuff and
do the same so that started giggling
hater so the most rewarding part of
duplicate and I guess sort of any
startup is actually seeing people use
your product and hearing about people
using something which you build and you
don't even know the person what what's
the gig locator oh you can find a
concert it's an app that helps you find
concerts
whenever you wherever and whenever you
want to go and he he's a huge success
story out of the he was probably he and
Paul goo were probably the most the
biggest financial successes out of that
first class and now James proud has this
new sense sleep tracker and it's this
little ball that's really nicely
designed I think was just named one of
Time Magazine's 25 best innovations of
the year last year what's it do it
tracks the environment where you sleep
and so it tells it can take it can
detect the air quality and it can tell
how you're sleeping and so I think
sports teams are starting to use it to
help their athletes and what is the
Peter teal think of his fellowship idea
at this point and he's been doing this
now for about five six years yeah well I
think I've talked to the foundation his
foundation about this and I think that
they would say that it's been a huge
success just because of the increase in
applications from four hundred to five
thousand and and also the the fellows
while they would say the goal wasn't
necessarily for all of them to become
billionaires but just to sort of stop
and think oh what else could I do do I
have to go to college do I have to do do
I have to do something like that and I
and I kind of do think that it's become
a model for for just having another up
for a gap year or there's there's been a
huge increase in that kind of those
deviations away from just going to
college and how much of what you saw
looks like what we're going to show now
from HBO's Silicon Valley program that
they do this the sitcom but how much of
it looks like this
watch I think all of it but anyway I'll
watch it I've already talked to Peter
Gregory about insourcing a consultant
I've made contact with the programmer
who's clad architecture is supposed to
be insane
they call him the carver the cover fur
that black hat guy who apparently hacked
into the Bank of America and took down
their entire system that the Carver we
should get it if we can okay we can talk
to the guy but I mean he's really gonna
have to sell me I think that's him
excuse me mr. Carver yeah people refer
to me as the Carver but no one actually
calls me that it's a people call a
screen name you know I'm Kevin okay
Kevin I feel like it's so accurate
what's an incubator oh it's a it's a
it's it's it it's a basically kind of
like a training center and so it breeds
companies and what we saw there I mean
Netherwood open space and lots of desks
yeah and so you can the Y Combinator
would be an example and so these you can
apply to one of these cut these
incubators or some of them you don't
have to apply to but this one but Y
Combinator for example will help hatch
an idea and you'll have mentors and
people helping you to to come up with
was something that could be eventually
worthwhile so what did you start to
realize about that whole crowd and as a
matter of fact I also want to ask you
what it was like leaving those I mean
they're clearly pride people yeah
but leaving that environment and going
back to your own other your other world
well that's a good I mean so what I
thought was so interesting about them
was their personality was there the way
they behaved was so different than the
people that I knew on the East Coast in
that they would have this huge amount a
lot of the people I talk to have these a
huge amount of knowledge in one
particular area and I have one chapter
title called Asperger chic which I mean
as a compliment
because it's sort of this this I
remember I was at a
conference where Peter teal was asked if
he thinks there's an ass for a spectrum
and he said not really I mean on the
extreme cases I'm sure he would but but
he said it's it's sort of this term that
people give that that smooth slick
people from the East Coast give to
people they can't understand and I think
he was he wasn't completely serious then
and that answer but it was one it is
sort of an interesting people that were
so focused on their one idea that they
were sort of awkward talking about other
things in a way because they weren't
that interested the business of they
would hire somebody who stutters over
somebody who does invasive similar to
what you're saying but in a different
way is that really true I mean it seems
like it's they'd be skeptical toward
people who were really smooth and we're
great at a cocktail party because that's
not really their job their job would be
to code or their job would be to come up
with some new crazy idea and so what's
this business about failing that's it so
yeah every drunk of positive
accomplishment if you fail well it's
funny
failing is the currency so whereas on
the East Coast you'd say oh we know each
other from and over there oh we know
each other from failing at our first
company so it's sort of they call they
call pivoting completely and utterly
failing there are all these nice ways of
saying fail and it almost seems like
it's a resume builder out there but it
seems now like it's a bit of a cliche
how great it is to fail but I mean I
failed many times and I don't think it's
that fun but it sort of goes with the
glorification of eating only ramen for
breakfast lunch and dinner and living
out of your car which isn't actually
that glamorous when I would interview
some of these people they they had tried
that and after a couple months it's
really not fun
so it does seem though in general
probably like a good thing to feel like
you're not going to be cast out for
failing but correct me if I'm wrong but
it appears to me there aren't many
people of color in this business yeah
that they're Asians yeah I didn't see
many Hispanics American African
what did you find I found the same thing
and I actually for my column at The Wall
Street Journal I interviewed this
entrepreneur named Tristan Walker and
he'd come up with this bevel shaving
system and it was straight even though
was a razor it was funded by a venture
capital firm and he calls it a tech
company but he has a foundation that
helps support minorities and and and/or
people African Americans and and and
underrepresented groups out there and I
asked him that question because I
thought because I I couldn't really
figure it out and his answer was that a
lot of a lot of in in in it starts with
colleges that a lot of colleges you know
the you don't see as many
african-americans in computer science
classes and and also just just more
encouragement just awareness that a lot
of that he was trying to help you he had
a he had a program during the summer
where he would bring inner-city kids and
and and and just African Americans in
general out there to work and just let
them know I'm gonna show you a clip of
Megan Kelly and this is as someone out
of context but I picked this up because
when reading your book I kept wanting to
ask you about the whole attitude about
today's society you grew up thirty Six's
you say you grew up in the last 20 years
and all that and she's talking about the
way she treats her children and about
the idea that everybody gets a trophy
uh-huh that's its brief lesson you're
bringing up your kids with the same
values of not everyone's a winner that
your guests brought you up with oh I've
already thrown away my son's
participation trophy it went right in
the garbage I know I'm sorry I did I
went to my daughter's school we had like
the parent-teacher conference at the
beginning and and she was like what what
would what is your core message to
Yardley and I said you are not special
not spam I mean you know these are
excuse me special people out there where
you can cut tubes listen to them great
do they feel special and and is that the
good thing to tell each other it were
special well you know
way in a way a lot of people to have the
confidence and the lack of awareness and
the or the lack of humility to follow
through with one of these big ideas I
kind of feel like it's not a bad thing
to feel special I mean if you thought
that your average then it's hard to hard
to come up with a crazy new idea like
that but it's funny I had a book idea of
one time to write a book called American
coddle about having to have too many
kids get positive read how kids get too
much positive reinforcement and it kind
of does lead to these huge expectations
and then dramatic failures and a lot of
the kids actually experience that I mean
it helped get them there the the feeling
of being special literally and
figuratively but because they were
chosen for that but um but once they got
there and they didn't have this huge
success a couple of them felt really
isolated and they really wanted to go
back and they were confused as to why
this hadn't happened yet one or two got
really depressed I mean they're doing
fine now I think those those two that
I'm thinking of one back to college so
so were you called yeah for sure yeah
and but I wouldn't really have it any
other way
I mean I kara they complain what did
your dad say about your book Oh what do
you think about the back did he
criticize it at all well he he's very
biased so I think he liked it but um but
he was really helpful than that he I
hadn't read it and he would say when he
was he would always say put in dialogue
whenever if a passage got really boring
he did say create a scene or you know
you really need to tell a story of what
these people are like and what are they
where he's always been really helpful in
reminding me to write details then he is
this tactic that that I he was way
better at than I am
about getting into a character's head
and when I read his books and he
describes oh this person was thinking
this he well he wouldn't come out there
and say that but it's it's through the
eyes of another character I really sound
like that whereas I have to keep going
back and say so did you think this at
this exact moment and the
I don't remember and I'd say well do you
remember what you did think that I was
three years ago you know so my father
was pretty conscientious him in his
note-taking I think he really I think
he's so observant of every interview and
theme he goes into so that definitely
helped to fill things out a little bit
you can find our guest in the Wall
Street Journal twice a week this is her
first book she's a resident of New York
City and the name of the book is valley
of the gods a Silicon Valley story Thank
You Alexandra wolf very much thank you
very much
[Music]
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
Q&A org Q&A programs are also available
as c-span podcasts
[Music]